[Music]
hey you guys
tomes of terror which means that it's
time to talk about another
horror novel now this one right here
is called the devil crept in
by anya alborn i think i'm pronouncing
that correctly
this is actually the second anya alborn
uh book that i've reviewed on the show
if you remember
i read um like a an ebook of if you see
her i think it was the first episode of
this series
and uh i liked that quite a bit this one
i think is
is better just be mostly because um i
really really liked
the main protagonist now this book came
out in 2017 and i'd seen it uh
recommended on a couple of other
booktube channels
and since i liked um if you see her
then i figured you know this would be
the logical next one to go with
and as i said i'm pretty sure like as i
liked uh if you see her but i think i
liked this one a little bit better
so if you want to read this book i'm not
going to spoil the ending
but i will probably spoil some plot
points
in there uh so if you like to go into
things like i do
not knowing you're or is knowing as
little as possible about what the story
is and like what
you know twists and turns happen then
probably you want to read it first
and then come back and uh we can discuss
it then because i am like i said i'm not
going to spoil the end but i might spoil
some
stuff uh you know plot twists and things
like that that you might not want
spoiled so
you've been warned so we're seeing this
story from the perspective of a
ten-year-old boy
named stevie clark and he lives in deer
valley oregon
with his mom and his older brother
duncan who he calls dunk
and they're horrible uh [ __ ] of a
stepfather whose name is terry
now stevie it's never specified what
exactly
his mental health issue is he's
perfectly intelligent everything like
that however
he has almost kind of like a i almost
want to say it's kind of like almost
like tourette syndrome where he has like
these verbal tics
um where he tends to like repeat the
same word over and over or
um you know he'll say something and then
like a bunch of rhyming phrases like
after and he can't really
help himself and since we're seeing
things it's not in the first person it's
actually
it's limited third person so so we're
kind of like knowing what's going on in
his head and it's very frustrating for
him
because he's trying to you know
explain things he's trying to get things
out and he kind of has you know an idea
of what he wants to say but like his
brain is kind of disordered
and when he tries to talk you know it
doesn't come out the way he wanted
and as i said it's very frustrating for
him and because
all the adults in his life and his
brother and things like that
find him also very frustrating to talk
to because of the way that he
uh communicates he also significantly
has had trouble with seeing visual
hallucinations in the past some of which
have been pretty severe one that they
bring up a couple of times
in the story is that he hallucinated
that one of his hands like the fingers
had turned into worms or snakes or
something like that
and it made him shove his hand
into the garbage disposal so he actually
ended up losing
uh parts of two of his fingers you know
not surprisingly since he's got these
issues he's not a real popular kid like
everybody just thinks he's weird or
crazy
and no one will really hang out with him
even though as i said since we're seeing
the whole entire story from his point of
view he is actually a very
sympathetic character because you can
relate to
his frustration that sometimes he can't
express himself the way he wants to and
sometimes he sees things and
he's not sure if they're real or not and
he's aware that he has that and it's
just kind of like you know
as i said it makes maneuvering through
the world very uh difficult for him
and he's a very easy to like kid now the
only friend that he has
is his older cousin jude who i think is
12.
and jude lives next door jude's mom
mandy is stevie's mom's sister
now jude's father died not too long
before the events of the book
and ever since then jude has been kind
of like i don't want to say like a
delinquent
but he's kind of one of the he's a
little bit of a troublemaker like a
troublemaker kind of kid like he mouths
off
um you know he kind of he's kind of a
daredevil and like he
you know runs away and things like that
so he's like a little bit of a problem
child
but nothing you know too egregious or
nothing to and
as i said it's understandable uh because
of his the death of his father which
he's having a hard time adjusting to
now him and uh stevie hang out all the
time
and uh you know they built a fort out in
the woods and stuff jude's actually kind
of a dick
to stevie like kind of makes fun of his
uh you know verbal tics and things like
that
but there is there does seem to be some
genuine affection
uh on both sides mostly from stevie's
side because
like i said that's who we're seeing it
from so the first part of the book
probably the first hundred pages or so i
think is kind of like a slow build up
of their relationship and their fa
the family dynamic the kind of
frustration that stevie feels about
feeling like the all the adults in his
life don't really listen to him or
you know because of things that happen
in the past with his like visual
hallucinations and whatnot and find him
very frustrating to
listen to so you know he's a little bit
isolated
and uh but as i said still a sympathetic
character
so there's just a few hints in the first
part of the book
that something a little bit weird is
going on in this
small town the small town is called deer
valley it's in oregon there's
little things like um oh remember like
20 years ago where that little
i think he was a ten-year-old boy maybe
or no i think he was younger than that i
think he might have been six
this little boy named max who
disappeared into the woods one day
and they found him like way later they
found his
body and it was kind of like all uh it
had been buried and whatnot
it's almost kind of like that happened
but no one really wants to talk about it
uh there's also a thing where people in
town
don't want to have pets because their
pets
seem to disappear or wander off you know
wander off into the woods and never come
back
so there is kind of some there are some
hints early on that maybe something is
going on in the woods
that is not a real kosher so at one
point jude and stevie
are out in the woods they're working on
their tree fort or whatever
and jude ends up disappearing
now he's gone for quite a while stevie
is heartbroken of course because jude is
his only friend and he you know and he
loves him
it's also his cousin like i said so
he gets the idea into his head because
he's a big fan of like true crime like
detective type of shows like unsolved
mysteries and stuff
and he perceives that the people in town
are not really looking all that hard for
jude just because like i said jude is
kind of like a troublemaker
and so stevie thinks that nobody really
cares about him disappearing because
they just think he ran away they don't
think anything bad is happening
but stevie begins to suspect otherwise
um especially after he starts seeing
kind of shadows of things
like in the woods like kind of like a
monster he thinks he's
a monster now he's not entirely sure if
that's real or not because like i said
he does
have problems with visual hallucinations
but
it's enough for him to kind of spur
sperm into action
as far as trying to find jude himself
even though he's only a 10 year old kid
now obviously the adults in town they
are looking for jude but
as i said it's not like a real big
priority because everyone's like hey he
was just like kind of a
he was just kind of an [ __ ] that kid
and it's like you know he was always
causing trouble and he
probably ran away he'll be back and blah
blah blah so
stevie gets frustrated and decides he's
going to carry out his own investigation
now that goes on for a little while as i
said jude has gone for
i can't really remember how long he's
gone it's you know several days at least
and he's kind of it's on the news and
everything like that
but then one evening
jude comes back and he just like turns
up
on the porch like standing on the porch
of um
of his mom's house now stevie of course
is
overjoyed and you know wants to go over
there and like ask well you know what
happened to you who took you everything
like that but jude
seems not quite the same as he was when
he left
and it's almost kind of like because
his mom mandy is so happy that jude is
back
it's almost kind of like she's not
realizing
how different the kid is now um
so this is another thing that's very
frustrating for stevie because
stevie becomes convinced that when jude
was in the woods like something happened
to him
something took him uh you know the
monster or maybe there was somebody in
the woods that took him and kept him
and did something to him because now
he's not really
acting the same it's like every now and
then he'll kind of have
glimpses that jude is sort of like he
was before
but most of the time he's just acting
really really strange like he'll just
kind of like like blank out
um and then he starts having all these
weird physical symptoms where it seems
like he's scratching himself all the
time
it looks like a real bad sunburn like
his skin starts to kind of peel off and
like his lips are just constantly
chapped
and it's almost kind of like the adults
don't really
notice it or they just think oh well you
know he went under a trauma or whatever
he's back now everybody's happy
and let's just forget the whole thing
happened because there's kind of a lot
of that kind of stuff going on like in
this book where
the adults just kind of want to forget
about [ __ ] and like just move on with
life or whatever
so after all that happened like after
jude comes back
and if he starts acting weird and
everything and then the book kind of
takes like a
little bit of a left turn a little
detour and i think at that point it
becomes like part two
now in this part you're kind of going
back in time
somewhat i believe it's like 20 or 30
years or something like that
and we're following a woman
named rosamund and she was married to
the town doctor back then whose name was
ansel
and the one thing that she wanted more
than anything was
a baby but they tried and tried and she
couldn't get pregnant and she was just
getting really really um
you know she was very saddened by this
uh lack of being able to have children
and then tragedy strikes her again when
her husband ansel is killed in a car
accident
shortly after he's killed she kind of
has a freak out
and she just kind of gets in the car and
drives
and she ends up at this really weird
retreat type of place and it's run by
this
guy who's kind of like a biker dude
named
ras or like rasputin that's what it's
short for and it's almost kind of like a
bed and breakfast
but he said without the breakfast you
know it's like he just lets people stay
there
and it's almost like she's drawn to the
place and
she kind of tells him all of her
problems about you know her
not being able to have a baby and then
um you know you know her husband dying
and everything like that
and he basically asks her what would you
do
for you know to have a child and she
basically says
anything now this retreat as strange as
it is makes her feel a lot better she
actually ends up going home and then
shortly thereafter
she discovers that she is pregnant
now she's a little weirded out by this
because she didn't really remember
like her and her husband like having sex
before they died
before he died so she's kind of like
well huh i don't really know like it
doesn't really seem to occur to her all
that well
all that much like until later on so she
ends up giving birth
to a severely
deformed child that she
names otto it's left ambiguous
as to what otto is exactly but
as the story goes on you kind of it
keeps like switching back and forth from
the story of like stevie and jude
and the story of rosamund and otto as
he's growing up
pretty soon you're able to discover that
these two stories are
connected you know what i mean it
doesn't really take a rocket science to
figure out
what is going on with otto and because
particularly because they uh rosamund
lives
in this creepy old house like out on
this logging road
that has been a source of urban legends
and things like that like throughout the
town and which stevie and jude are kind
of like scared to go to
so from that point forward as the two
stories kind of like keep going back and
forth and
intersect jude starts to get more
and more [ __ ] up and he
starts to start running away
almost like he wants to go back to
whoever was keeping him
like when he was missing for all of that
time and as i said
stevie who's kind of like a very shy
very introverted a little bit you know
cowardly kind of kid
he sort of has to come to the
realization that
look no one is going to help jude nobody
knows what's going on but me
nobody believes me about there's a
monster in the woods nobody believes
that something's the matter with jude
and he's like so i have to figure this
out all on my own i have to save him
because he's my best friend
and so that's pretty much what the kid
has to end up doing
now interestingly i said i wasn't going
to spoil the end but
there is something that happens at the
end like in the epilogue that
sort of casts the entire story in maybe
a different light this might be like i
said this might be a little spoilery but
it's it's left ambiguous as to whether
stevie is a completely reliable
narrator because as i said he had
problems with visual hallucinations
before
um and his hallucinations were
horrifying
and were so real to him like i said that
he ended up maiming himself
uh at one point so the way that the
ending goes
it could go either way like either the
stuff in
the book happened exactly the way stevie
perceived it to have happened
or it happened differently and stevie
was just seeing it in a different way
because he was
hallucinating or he was like primed to
see it in that way
i think it's more likely that it really
did happen the way you know particularly
because
it starts going back and forth with the
story of rosamond uh
and her baby like otto uh and him
growing up and becoming like a monster
essentially i guess you're like led to
believe that stevie is perceiving things
correctly but it's just interesting
because
it seems like a lot of the townspeople
don't really
see things the same way that stevie sees
them
and i'm not really sure i think the
point of the book is
that poor stevie he's had such mental
health
health issues in the past and everybody
is kind of like used to
him seeing things and him not being able
to
explain things correctly because his you
know his disordered thoughts and whatnot
so it's almost kind of like when
something bad does happen
no one believes him because they just
think oh he's seeing things again like
he did that last time or maybe he's not
explaining it right because he can't
talk correctly
and all this other kind of stuff so i
think that the best thing about this
book
was just the depth of stevie's character
and how much you really felt for this
kid
because you could really put yourself
you know in the shoes of a ten-year-old
boy who had had these previous issues
and something horrific is happening to
the person you love more than anything
else in the world
and you're trying to get help from all
the adults around you and nobody
believes you or like no one will help
you and for him having to
you know essentially just like a 10 year
old kid having to go out there and like
save
his best friend or try to anyway um and
fighting against what he perceives is
maybe like a supernatural evil or
something like that
you know it's just a real it's kind of
like a heartbreaking
uh story because like so many terrible
things like happen to this poor kid
like i said this actually the second
anya alborn book that i've uh read
and uh i really liked it quite a bit it
was a real
enjoyable it's kind of like i said it
starts out kind of slow but not
not in a bad way it's kind of um it's
just building up the character building
up the relationships
you know building up you know the fact
that there's kind of this urban legend
[ __ ] about the woods and everything like
that so it's kind of like a slow start
but once
you you know once jude goes missing and
then comes back
and that whole thing then it's just kind
of like off to the races
once you get like to that point it's
really but like i said i think that
the first part of the book you needed
that because it's does it does really
good
for you to get into stevie's head you
really kind of like empathize with his
frustration
uh at everyone around him and not
helping him when he clearly
needs some help uh saving his cousin
so yeah so i thought that was like a
really great aspect of it it's a really
interesting story it's not like the most
original story ever but
it's just kind of like it's just done
really well very fast-paced once it gets
to
uh you know about the midpoint not even
the midpoint like 100 pages in
and then it just kind of goes it's very
very
gruesome like some pretty uh grody [ __ ]
happens in this
um a lot of uh trauma against
animals lots of trauma against
children um just really really horrible
horrific stuff happens so if you don't
like real gruesome like gory [ __ ] like
it doesn't
there's not much of it in the beginning
but the more it goes on like the more
and more
grisly it gets you know what i mean
until like the end you're like holy crap
you know what i mean
so it does kind of go in that direction
so just know that going in before you
read it
but yeah overall um i really had a good
time with this book it's just a real fun
it's not like
you know it's not like super deep or
super anything like that it was just
like a fun
you know just a fun enjoyable like
horror ride
and you know so so in that way i thought
it was like you know a really really
good really entertaining book with a
really really good
sympathetic uh central protagonist who
like i said you know you're rooting for
this kid like the whole way through
and it's just so um a lot of times it's
like really
it's really heartbreaking to see because
it's like he's just so
young and he just has all these
limitations and
you know the fact that he has to be
brave and like do all this stuff anyway
so it really really makes you kind of
like love this kid
and honestly it's like even though the
way that he talks
because i saw a couple of um reviews of
this on maybe goodreads or something
like that
where a couple people thought well the
way that he talks was like too
like it was too annoying like they
couldn't really read through it but i
don't really find that to be the issue
yes he does like repeat himself a lot
and sometimes he will say a sentence but
then he like comes up with all these
rhyming phrases
like that rhymes with like the last word
of the sentence or whatever but actually
i didn't that didn't bother me i
actually found it kind of charming
or like kind of endearing because i
could kind of i could picture the kid
and i could like hear his voice and i
could hear the stuff that he was saying
so that didn't really uh
bother me at all your mileage may vary
of course but yeah so
again just uh just a real decent fun
horror read with pretty gruesome little
might be
a little bit of supernatural kind of
[ __ ] not a lot supernatural but it does
have a little
bit of a supernatural maybe demonic sort
of thing
it's mostly like based in the real world
kind of but there is a little bit of a
supernatural element
but yeah so i would definitely recommend
it and i will uh likely be reading some
more of her stuff because she's got a
bunch of other
books that are also well reviewed
because i liked these first two so much
like i said i like this one probably
better than the first one of hers that i
read
but yeah this is called the devil
krypton anya alborn and it came out in
2017
and that'll do it for this tomes of
terror and i will see you guys on the
next one
bye